bonjour à tous et bienvenue à la
conférence de presse de thomery jen ai
cessé sans plus attendre je vous demande
d'accueillir le réalisateur au alors en
championnat go travel et le réalisateur
emilio club sarthois
nice to meet you c'est à vous la
première question micro de suite voilà
bonjour je l'aurais aimé savoir ce qu'il
y avait d'excitant août et défrayant de
reprendre un film culte tort de prendre
la suite d'un film culte de l'intégrer
pour pour la chaîne l'actrice et de le
reprendre pour le pour un homme soit
deux guerres il ma deuxième question
c'est il répète tout le temps dans le
film le personnage répète tout le temps
je suis vieux mais pas obsolète
est ce que c'est pour arnold choisi de
guerre une façon de faire sa promo pour
les futurs réalisateurs john woo
évidemment que pour moi y avait deux
choses
intimidant si je puis dire d'abord dire
oui c'est effectivement ce film et tout
sa mythologie parce que james cameron
avait fait un travail extraordinaire sur
les deux premiers films et donc j'ai
décidé de me focaliser moins sur la
franchise est davantage effectivement
sur la relation humaine au sein du film
et bien sûr mbia je la connaissais donc
pour moi c'était évidemment plus facile
autre chose intimidante bien sûr c'est
d'avoir à travailler avec quelqu'un qui
connaît mieux que personne ce personnage
ce terminator et donc de lui trouver des
choses qui l'intéresserait et qu'il
passionnerait également dans cette
nouvelle aventure easyhotel iguazu step
into ses sketches mais c'est vrai que
pour moi c'est vrai que c'était assez
effrayant comme vous l'avait dit et mais
justement c'est la raison aussi qui m'a
poussé à être dans ce film parce que
comme actrice évidemment c'est un défi
de taille est de savoir que j'allais
voir comme même temps quelque sorte
terminator ça c'était encore plus
extraordinaire mais la joie vraiment
lorsque j'ai découvert le scénario j'ai
vu à quel point sahara était un
personnage complètement différent et que
donc j'avais un terrain riche et fertile
pour moi en tant qu'actrice d'explorer
de grandir en tant qu'actrice
et puis également de lui donner d'autres
couleurs tout en étant bien entendu
fidèle à l'esprit que lui avait insufflé
carbone et bien sûr linda hamilton you
back
mais le mauvais temps 1 2
alors voilà c'est vrai que pour moi
l'excitation a commencé quand j'ai reçu
ce coup de fil juste un mois après avoir
terminé la fonction de gouverneur quand
megan est david ellison m'ont appelé ils
m'ont demandé j'ai été intéressé tout de
suite j'ai dit oui j'adorerais mais à
une condition qu'il y ait un bon
scénario
ils m'ont dit qu'il allait racheter les
droits de la franchise qu'ils allaient
produire et effectivement trouver de
grands scénaristes à la hauteur d'un tel
défi et c'est ainsi que cela commençait
30 ans donc après ma première aventure
ils ont véritablement réussi à créer un
scénario extraordinaire et ensuite ils
ont ils ont mis ensemble une équipe avec
de vrais talents talent aussi bien au
niveau des de l'écriture mais des effets
visuels spéciaux des cascadeurs et
évidemment des acteurs qui allaient
m'entoure et donc c'était ils ont été
extrêmement précieux et précis en cela
pour moi est donc ça fait 7 cette
aventure m'a rendu très excitante et
donc j'étais content d'être de retour
fritzl a maintenant obsolète vous au
seuil fouilloux en tout c'est est ce que
les biotopes job to fall directeur doit
battre au sprint
trois jours de fête
fx instant deuxième de canaux et de
signer ces protéines stein tu es ce que
tu n'es qu'un bwin épouse au film de gad
peter
il est exact que nous
c'est tout alors je te veux dire que
d'abord je ne suis pas quelqu'un avec
qui il est difficile de travailler mais
c'est vrai qu'il est intimidant pour les
autres finalement de s'emparer d'une
telle franchise parce que c était une
des franchises les plus populaires de
tous les temps
mais c'est vrai que j'ai été très
heureusement surpris lorsque on m'a dit
que c'était alors qu'ils allaient
réaliser ce film parce que dès ma
première constation avec lui j'ai vu
qu'il avait une vision très claire ce
qui est extrêmement important chez un
réalisateur car ainsi on ne perd pas
t'en aller de l'un à l'autre on sait
exactement où on va et c'est ce qu'a
fait alain il a suivi le scénario de
façon extraordinaire et grâce à son
expérience avec les effets visuels et
effets spéciaux les cascadeurs et bien
il a vraiment amené quelque chose de
plus dans un film qui est vraiment d'une
envergure exceptionnelle ce qui la fait
qu'ils étaient très important c'est
qu'il a créé une synergie entre tous les
talents au cas où cvc comme dans une
équipe de football de rugby de basket
ball peu importe on peut chaque un vrai
talent merveilleux de façon isolée mais
encore faut-il que l'équipe soit
cohérente et regardent dans la même
direction pour justement gagné donc ici
c'était la même chose c'était une
production extrêmement complexe et dès
le départ grâce à l'expérience à lens
avec sa vision son expérience de nouveau
tout de suite
il nous a fait
une expérience commune et ça a été pour
moi vraiment merveilleux je me suis
senti tout de suite entre de bonnes
mains
parce qu'il a à la fois le leadership et
en même temps la connaissance et ça par
exemple à certains moments il acceptait
complètement que je lui dise tu sais je
crois que terminator ne ferait pas ça et
à long terme alors comment est ce qu il
ferait donc avait une ouverture d'esprit
une générosité dont vraiment c'était
pour moi formidable et puis c'est vrai
que le cast tous les acteurs étaient
extraordinaires emilia par exemple dès
que j'ai su qu'elle allait tourner et
être évidemment ça et bien j'avoue je
n'avais pas garder tous les épisodes de
sa série
donc j'en ai jaunes demandaient avec mon
équipe on en a regardé plusieurs et donc
je connaissais son jeu ses performances
avant même d'arriver sur le tournage s
qui était formidable c'est qu'elle a su
transformer le personnage de sarah et je
ne parle pas seulement de la couleur de
ses cheveux mais elle lui a donné une
attitude un une façon de se mouvoir qui
était très différente donc ce qui fait
que pour moi ça a été extraordinaire
comme expérience à la fois grâce au
réalisateur mais aussi au talent qui
étaient autour de moi autres et voilà
soyouz you're not absolut d'affiner
votre question oui mais wayne à des
actions de rim est george bush à propos
de camping voilà c'est une question à
propos des 70 lorsque arnold
schwarzeneger bien sûr faisait du
bodybuilding et nous savons à quelle à
quel niveau extraordinaire est ce qu'il
pensait cette époque là que toute sa vie
il allait faire des films d'action
quelque sorte et une deuxième question
rapport atteint bengoreine même chose il
n'était pas sûr au début d'avoir envie
de faire cela
et c est au commencement du come back in
town protéger tous pareils
alors voilà donc pour ce qui concerne
les petits mondes prenez garde la raison
était simple cas au départ je n'étais
pas sûr c'est que j'avais arrêté la
compétition ma carrière vraiment
compétition en 74 ils sont venus me voir
en 75
évidemment comme un documentaire cela
demandait donc que je retourne en
compétition des dons de convaincre de
refaire des compétitions de meuron
montré en entraînement et ses terrains
donc voilà c'est la seule raison sinon
c'était un
un super documentaire surtout à l'époque
le bodybuilding et est encore un sport
assez méconnu donc c'était vraiment pour
cela en ce qui concerne effectivement ce
que je faisais des années 70 lorsque je
faisais du bodybuilding ma vision à ce
moment là c'est vrai c'était d'être dans
le cinéma de médan cimade d'action donc
c'est vrai que ma vision mon but était
assez limité à l'époque je pensais bien
que les ou conan
mais voilà je rouge pouvait
effectivement utilisé mon corps mais
après deux cas au nom m'a proposé
terminator et là c'était formidable
parce que ça a été j'ai enfin pu briser
en quelque sorte cette image de moi qui
était uniquement associé à un physique
même si dans termine et on peut voir
dans une fan en particulier que le corps
est là et bien présent mais le reste du
temps
j'ai un blouson de cuir je suis habillé
et donc ça m'a permis acteurs minettes
de passer à un autre stade est d'avoir
une carrière qui enfin allait partir
évidemment bien au delà des films
d'action question oui je sais qu'une
création
alors voilà première caisse première
phase i de la question est ce que c'est
le même plaisir pour un homme d'être à
la fois de jouer dans des films d'action
bien d'en jouer dans des drames comme
faisant ma geek et 106 qui est
formidable et quelques mots sur son
incroyable bague simple tous les après
midi
le plaisir est bien il est identique que
je fasse documentaire des drames la
science fiction des comédies voilà des
films de fantasy
la clé c'est toujours la qualité du
scénario et la qualité des gens avec qui
je vais travailler c'est un peu comme de
me demander voilà qu'est ce que je
préfère manger la wiener schnitzel aux
biens de l'apple strudel les deux les
deux sont des plaisirs différents ce qui
compte pour moi c'est d'être passionné
est justement de vie des aventures
passionnantes
en ce qui concerne les bacs bien lui en
a une c'est la bague terminator et
l'autre c'est la bague gouverneur donc
je ne sais pas de quel bac vous vous
voulez parler
autre question bonjour en creux une
question pour emilia est-ce qu'elle a
revu les deux premiers films escales
s'est inspiré du jeu de linda hamilton
parce que linda hamilton commence dans
le premier film en étant la fille qu'on
doit sauver elle termine en prenant les
armes et question bonus c'est pas la
première actrice de game of thrones a
joué sarah connor puisque l'ena et d'hec
qui joue cersei à jouer sarah commandant
de sarah connor chronicles est ce qu
elles le savaient ce qu'elles en ont
parlé de cet oubli nomine du x show made
in the bad and the queen a dit
alors voilà c'est vrai que effectivement
dandin période de préparation du
tournage j'ai regardé les deux premiers
films il demande de te mêler mais
c'était vraiment pendant qu on
additionnait et lorsque j'ai reçu le
scénario que j'ai vu les différences
énormes qu'il y avait entre les deux les
deux stars en quelque sorte
j'ai arrêté de regarder ses films pour
justement m'approprier moi même ce
personnage j'ai créé ma propre sarah
cornes et en ski ou salines c'est vrai
que c'est on a rit beaucoup
au départ et des villes est dingue sur
les showrunners de games of thrones et
sont encore d'un meilleur mais il va
falloir une bataille entre vous deux
mais ce patient qui va gagner
voilà vous dit tout haut ce n'est guère
se fait journaliste pour nous est dit
voilà moi j'aimerais bien que tu nous
parles de tout l'entraînement de la
transformation physique pour passer
effectivement 2 de game of thrones
ajustements sarah de 2009 puisque arnaud
et moi j'en ai vu un des entraînements
et suis là franchement formidable
alors voilà c'est vrai que mon
personnage très danault et c'est bien
elle elle est plutôt habitué à manier
l'épée
donc je dois dire je n'étais pas très
habitués à amani effectivement les les
pistolets les les armes à feu donc ça je
me suis aperçu que en plus je n'étais
pas assez costaud pour même pouvoir
soulever parfois certaines armes à feu
qui était extrêmement lourd donc j'ai dû
vraiment en quelque sorte me rendre me
renforcer musculairement pour avoir le
corps est là et la force de sa crainte
puisque de façon d'amener c'est plutôt
les dragons qu'elle laissait qu'elle
laissait faire quand il veut genre de
choses alors un oeil aux demies est ce
que tu as également dû faire d'autres
choses à 11 28 ans terme peut-être de de
dia toute chose comme ça dit oui en fait
j'ai dû pour avoir construit d avoir
plus de muscle victime en est bien avoir
un régime très protéines et pour garder
l'énergie pas seulement pour grossir mes
muscles mais aussi parce que les jours
étaient très longs et les jours de
tournage était très long très physique
donc il fallait vraiment que j'ai un
régime adapté qui me garde en pleine
forme qu'elle tire aucune question
les deux bagues pour la première bague
la vague de 2 terminateur je veux savoir
comment il apparaît jeune on le voit
jaune avec son visage de jeune dans le
film quelle est la technique a été
utilisée est pour l'autre bague je
voulais savoir il ya une actualité un
peu tragique aux états unis avec le
drame de charleston je voulais savoir
comment le gouverneur républicain qu'il
ait réagi à ce drame et surtout à la
réaction du président obama qui a semblé
un peu parce que exprimé un peu de
découragement face à des drames comme ça
en disant que les états unis étaient
sans doute le seul pays au monde où on
pouvait vivre ce genre de drame
voilà
oui c'est business mauvais to play hd2
est aussi exact les deux scènes de
violence des deux fois
et les optiques mistake du poteau par la
haine en france
or ces choses là ok alors dans la
première partie de la question
évidemment c'est vrai que dans le film
effectivement on a on assez différent
ce d'âge sur mon personnage et c'est
vrai que moi lorsque je traverse les
époques et bien effectivement il doit y
avoir un changement sur moi mais ce qui
était formidable dans le scénario
c'était très bien écrit dès le départ on
savait que ce serait ridicule ça ne
marcherait pas si j'avais le même look
que en 1984 et nous n'avons pas essayé
pour que justement ce soit très réaliste
ce que nous faisions malgré tout donc
lorsqu'il ya par exemple ce combat que
je fait contre moi même enfin contre
moi-même en 1984 et bien allen avait
trouvé un bodybuilder qui me ressemblait
assez bien au niveau quand même de la
force de la puissance
un peu comme à monsieur univers mais
c'est vrai que j'étais un peu sous 6 en
10 ans mais ils ne bougent pas
exactement la tête comme moi ou il n'a
pas exactement les mêmes mouvements
physiques que moi donc c'était c'était
c'était le seul questionnement vraiment
que j'avais et d'ailleurs lorsque j'ai
vu le film pour la première fois il ya
trois semaines j'étais complètement
époustouflés de voir le résultat sur
écran parce que j'avais vraiment la même
tête je me battais contre moi-même
exactement comme j'étais en 1984 donc
c'était absolument incroyable et c'est
vrai que cette scène en réalité elle a
été tournée en avril ou mai de l'an
dernier elle a mis à peu près un an en
post-production à être à être fait donc
c'est pour ça que l on pourra peut-être
vous en dire davantage mais parce qu'un
post production a été un travail très
difficile mais c'était extraordinaire
est la seule question que je me suis
posée en voyant ce combat c'était mais
finalement qui j'ai envie de voir gagner
en ce qui concerne la basse vous parliez
tout à l'heure vous aviez dit
républicain et gouverneurs et je crois
que c'est une grande erreur que de
mettre le nom d'un parti associé à une
fonction aussi importante
je pense que c'est qu'il ne faut pas
avoir des réactions partisanes on est de
droite on est de gauche on républicains
et des démocrates
ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on gagne on
gagne en étant comme je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure sur un tournage donc quand c'est
un travail d'équipé et il est très très
important bien sûr on peut avoir des
débats sur différentes questions
mais les très importants justement
d'aller au delà du débat là il s'agit
d'une tuerie dans une église
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec les case
habituelle politique savoir avec un
problème humain et social qui est
fondamental parce que au fond
il ya des choses qu'il faut sur lequel
il faut agir qui sont des problèmes de
société on sait que par exemple aux
états unis il y a trente personnes
minimum par jour qui se tue dans le dans
les chais les militaires il ya le post
jean racine jobs après les guerres il ya
tout cela c'est cela qui est important
c'est tout ce sont tous ces problèmes et
si nous voulons réussir si l'amérique où
tout le monde de réussir
et bien il ne s'agit pas de parler de
partie mais de réunir au contraire tous
les partis et de travailler ensemble à
des solutions ensemble
question 1 dernière question la
situation qui chagrine mister you know
me by mr taylor directeur konan mauvais
alors voilà donc c'est vrai que
terminator et is back bientôt konan
aussi est-ce que à notre chance les gars
a déjà des noms de réalisateurs à
l'esprit et sk l'inter peut être
aimerait s'attaquer
movieline cependant batman voilà donc
c'est drôle que vous posiez cette
question parce qu'à des jeunes est
justement d'en parler avec alan et je
lui disais ça serait quand même ce
vraiment bien que si tu pouvais réaliser
aussi conne parce que comme je disais
tout à l'heure
très peu de réalisateurs ont le talent à
la fois de connaître ce genre de film
d'être vraiment adepte aux effets
spéciaux aux cascades ex terrain et
allen est de ceux là donc ils sont très
rares et vraiment allen est de ceux là
en ce qui concerne justement que je
reprenne ses konan là aussi il s'agit
d'un miracle si on m'avait dit il ya 35
ans que de nouveaux jeux seraient connus
lundi mais c'est pas possible cette
initiation donc très inhabituelle parce
que par exemple quand on pense au james
bond au batman hawks terrain on change
les acteurs tous les cinq six sept ans
peu importe
et là c'est vrai que c'est une exception
puisque on me garde moi comme acteur
pour cela il faut dire qu'avec un corps
comme le mien ça se comprend
et c'est comme ça que se conclut cette
question ce que j'ai séduit philémon
résumé je le sais
alors vous l'avez compris c'est vrai que
pour moi ça me donne l'opportunité de
dire à quel point j'ai eu un incroyable
plaisir à travailler avec arnold parce
que bien sûr il est connu
quand comme un immense acteur il a une
personnalité étonnante il a une vie
aussi riche et extraordinaire donc
j'avais aucune idée avant de rencontrer
ce gentleman de quelle personne
finalement j'allais rencontrer et ça a
été un plaisir infini et donc je
profiterai pour lui filer mon cv tout à
l'heure à la fin de la conférence de
presse en we cannot end et ce presque en
france où ayew 5 want you back